[Music]
all right welcome everyone once again to
grandmaster's choice I am uh woman
Grandmaster Talia santes and um last
week we kind of had the topic of
committing to a move right and kind of
deciding where we should go for a move
where it's the right moment whether we
should have a breakthrough in our
position is there a tactical idea all of
that stuff
uh we looked at an example in which it
is good to go for for a sacrifice and
then we also looked at a position in
which um it looked very natural to go
for a sacrifice but it wasn't 100% sure
and then it kind of just shows the
reality of chest right like sometimes
you know that you should go for a
sacrifice sometimes you just don't know
so it's a mixture of intuition and
calculation that's kind of the main
point of everything that I want to um to
to Showcase and today is kind of a
continuation of that right I have three
examples from three of my games we're
kind of going over them and at the same
time uh try to build up some
understanding and intuition on when it's
good to make a sacrifice and what not
right so this first example that we have
right here is actually from a game of
mine from
2019 and I played it at the FKS Woods
open um really strong tournament here in
the
US and my opponent and I we arrived to
this position from a queen scan Decline
and after a lot of complications in the
center we ended up having this open
position as you can probably see the
last move from my opponent here was
Bishop to D7 and there's a reason why
there's a question mark in that move
right so essentially before we start
answering
questions um or suggesting moves about
the position I want to bring some some
light into um how we should evaluate the
position before getting
started and in this position right here
I want to ask what are some of the most
uh noticeable factors right um like how
are the Kings uh in terms of safety are
the pieces well placed who has better
placed pieces uh what does the p
structure tell you things like that
right so what are some some factors that
we can
notice uh from this
position are there any ideas or are we
just like oh well not my position so I
don't
care
someone says that they want to take with
a
bishop and this makes a lot of sense
right like when you're looking for
candidate moves obviously you want to um
to look at checks captures and threats
right in this particular position I
don't don't don't know Chucks uh but we
really have to start thinking about
captures right um as well as threats
so it is a kind of common sense to
consider moves like Pawn takes or Bishop
takes things like that in terms of
threats you might consider Rook
E7 um maybe
92 there are there are a lot of moves to
consider maybe 94 as well I'm not sure
right so yeah like for example so almost
said Knight E2 if Queen takes Bishop C4
right this is a big problem but it all
kind of ties it back U as well as the
idea of Bishop G6 it all kind of ties it
back to where I was trying to reference
of like where's the key in the position
right and clearly it has to do with the
bad shape of the of the black king and
how we need to find a way to get to it
quickly right before there is some sort
of Defense before um there is some sort
of um you know uh way for black to to
get some Counterattack on the way right
because they also have some ideas of
Knight G4 which we should not um uh
forget
about so in this particular position I
was playing with the white pieces as I
was saying and the whole point is like
whether do I take on
G6 or whether do I do something else
right and I was thinking very long very
hard in this position over the board and
eventually um eventually I realized that
um either it was this moment or no other
right right sometimes when you are in a
position um most of the times I would
say like you feel it more over the board
but you can kind of tell
when there's a critical moment right
it's like that moment in which in which
you need to stop think for for some time
maybe spend a little bit more time than
usual like 10 to 15 minutes try to fully
assess what's going on at the board and
then make a decision right and depending
on what you do the
the the position itself is going to
completely shift right so you really
have to make sure that what you do is
right so a lot of people are saying
Bishop G6 in this position but I'm
wondering like did you calculate
anything beyond that like what are some
variations for you guys to be
recommending Bishop G6 because at the
same time we really have to be looking
for Black's defenses as well right we
can't just assume oh it's not my game
Bishop takes G6 and then we'll figure
out later what happens right like
there's got to be some some substance to
to this move right obviously you have to
consider what happens if Pawn takes but
there are some other moves that black
can do because taking back is not forced
right so what to
do
so there's one comment which um is right
so if we play Bishop takes G6 obviously
uh there are different moves that black
can make but we're going to focus first
of all what happens if Pawn takes right
and the idea is that after Queen G6 King
h8 unfortunately we can't just uh
Checkmate the king with the queen alone
but we can bring a rook into the game
right it really helps the fact that
in this
position after Bishop D7 all of our
pieces are already in the center or
looking towards the towards the
the the king side right so after uh
Bishop takes takes Queen G6 King H Rook
E7 there's not really a way to to
counteract all of the threats right
because there is this going on uh if
this Knight moves and there's Queen H7
as well so there are just too many
threats and it's impossible to take care
of all of them right like for example
Rook G8 Queen H6 and the position is
winning
so right so that's what happens if Pawn
decides to take but there's another move
right that we really have to consider
which is the move that happened in the
game and it's the reason why I was
thinking for so long about Bishop to G6
and again I want to emphasize how it is
is important to always be looking for
the resources that the opponent has to
defend right we can't just uh have tunal
Vision into one variation when we do a
sacrifice because maybe the opponent has
some other resources that we did not
take into account and then we give up
some material for nothing right so um
right now I want to talk about Knight to
G4 which is actually the move that was
playing in the game and I know that
there's a question mark here but it is
the move that POS the most challenge to
me right because it's not really a
defense it's more of a Counterattack
right um which is a lot more scary so
Knight G4 the idea is that in the future
after takes takes uh the Knight on F6 is
not going to be hanging and it's harder
to play Rook E7 because there are more
open files for the rook and then at the
same time there's this threat of Knight
to F2 right so did any of you consider
this move Knight G4 first of
all CU I feel like the answer is no but
I need you guys to to tell
me I did after leech just drew the white
Arrow well maybe I shouldn't have
um is there a way for me need to delete
those I
wonder ah yes show variation arrows very
good okay that's turned off now I learn
something new every day yeah yeah
yeah jokes on you now I know your
tricks um but see I'm getting a lot of
comments I'm getting a lot of comments
that no they didn't consider Knight to
G4 but imagine this was your game
imagine this was your your game and then
you miss Knight G4 and then you are like
oh whoops and you you know you just
spend maybe like 10 minutes calculating
Bishop G6 and now you only thought about
I mean now you have to deal with Knight
G4 right and then you have to spend a
lot more time maybe bishop G6 doesn't
work anymore and you miss that so
um that's why it's important that's why
it's important to take uh defensive
resources into account and that's why I
also try to emphasize a little bit
um the need to to calculate calculate
variations or calculate moves with
threats right not just forcing moves of
captures and checks but also threats
so what should we do here after Knight
G4 which again is what happened in my
game but I was ready for it
so how can why continue you got yourself
into this mess now you need to get
yourself out of
it
there's one suggestion for
H3 but I fear that H3 might be a little
bit
slow uh I feel like H3 might be a little
bit slow because let's see I'm
considering Knight of2 directly there's
also a thread that I forgot to um to
mention which could be quite deadly not
just Knight F2 Knight F2 looks good to
me
um because if King H2 there might be
Queen 2 F4 and that looks pretty strong
um but at the same time you also have to
take into consideration something like
takes takes Knight E3 right and then
it's not so clear it's still very
complex um what's going on at the at the
board because there's Bishop takes H7
but then King King h8
and
then
um then it's hard to say what's going on
because for example let's say you want
to play like Queen G6 Knight takes Queen
H6 do you have some sort of discover
attack there is always Queen G7 which is
a very big problem right
so unfortunately I don't think you're
going to see a Checkmate here with the
queen and the bishop at least not in
this way like if the queen was in front
of the bishop then it's a whole
different story
uh but H3 might be a bit
slow again like Bishop G6 was a very
Dynamic move right so Knight to G4 gets
the position even more tense so now we
have to keep amping up the pressure
until the opponent just breaks right
because um we really need to have some
some powerful move here so H3 doesn't
cut it just for
now there are Al such suggestions for uh
Bishop takes H7 but my question is like
again uh did you calculate the full
variation because after King to h8 like
obviously I'm going to go to h8 and not
to G7 because there's Queen G6 so after
King to H what would you want to do uh
because again all of the threats are
still at large
right there is um there is the idea of
Rook takes a knight E3 there is Knight
F2 uh there are some ideas even of Queen
E5 which is a little bit funny because
um if Rook takes takes right
um I lost to you in Chicago open I think
uh well interesting I've played Chicago
open a few
times sometimes it went really well
sometimes it went absolutely terrible
but
um
yeah so it looks like no one is really
suggesting mov after Bishop to H7 and
King
h8 I don't know if there is like another
idea but this is kind of what I meant
like you always have to look and move
further right you can't just cut the
variation um while your opponent still
has threats that you have not covered
right um so in this position right
here I think Knight to D1 was another uh
suggestion um another move
recommended Knight 2
E1 Knight 2 E1 I did not consider this
move uh let's see what could possibly be
wrong with
it maybe there's nothing wrong with
it
maybe okay so I guess
uh okay I guess there is is this right
something like takes
takes well you don't even have to play
King shade you can play Queen G7 right
and then all of a sudden because the
Knight is not on F6 Our Queen can go
back right and then this becomes a a big
issue as well in the
attack so like I said here we kind of
have to play with some with some more
action another move that was recommended
was Bishop to F7 but again I kind of
need like Fuller variations I can't just
uh um accept one move because for
example Bishop to
F7 uh first of all I kind of need an an
answer for Rook takes F7 but at the same
time there's also like King G7 or King
h8 right so um I would be curious to
see what the what the followup
is
just want it to be included don't worry
you're always
included um
yeah so for example let's say um
takes obviously we're going to take take
and then Queen H7
right and here the main question would
be uh what happens after King h8 right
because we don't have enough time to
take here because oops guess what we get
into a we get into a smaller mate right
and this is not good so what do we do
here
it's actually a very
funny variation in my
opinion let me check on Wikipedia very
good Quin check on the E file I'm
guessing you mean queen E7 but again
like um King goes here right they move
the Knight to eile like
94 okay
um feel like there might still be some
problems because we are in a position
with
um like having a piece up right
so let's
see maybe there is
this I think it works Rook here and then
if Queen takes then hauh we have this
again because if Knight takes then Rook
takes
right so that might be a
problem again we got to keep the
activity going
right
yes so there is one right suggestion
which is actually Rook
F1 and then the idea is that this King
has to commit right um if the Knight
goes back to to F6 then there's Queen h8
uh you could even take on D7 actually
because there's a pin and the the black
king is completely in the open um if
King here then there is Queen G8 and
most importantly if Knight F2 which is
kind of the critical variation King G1
but guess what in this position because
of the pin there is no Discovery with
the Knight so next move we can actually
play Rook takes F2 and then the position
is completely winning for
white um
so yeah it's kind of funny right because
there's like a double there's like a
double pin going on but we actually get
to capture on F two and then like I said
the the blacking is completely open and
it's not going to find shelter anytime
soon so we are complet winning here with
the with the white pieces and on top of
that we're going to be material up uh
after we take here on on
F2 yeah you saw this after Bishop F7 I'm
sure of it I'm sure of it uh just want
to give a chance to to the rest of the
of the chat
exactly
um yeah okay so that's what happens yeah
that's what happens after after ruk
takes uh um Rook takes F7
right but this move Bishop F7 is very
very crucial right because it completely
blocks the connection that The Rook has
um on the f file and since we know that
capturing is not going to be an option
for black then this gives us an extra
turn right because they have to make a
move with the King they have to waste
the tempo and in this particular
position time is of the essence
right so Bishop to F7 and then after
this the position went on kind of
kind of smoothly right but if we're
being completely honest I played uh
Bishop takes G6 without actually
seeing um the idea of Rook F1 without
actually seeing Rook F1 Knight F2 and
then King G1 I just thought okay Bishop
takes G6 has to work because all of my
pieces are involved in the in the game
right so it has to work somehow I
thought that you know at least least
worst case scenario I can have uh some
sort of like repetition in the in the
board and then it's going to be
completely fine but actually after I
played Bishop G6 and my opponent was
thinking then I kept on calculating and
then I realized that I had Rook F1 and
King G1 so that was very very fortunate
but at the same time if you remember
last week when we talked about uh
Kasparov how he played Knight to H6
maybe you guys were here maybe not it
was a good lecture uh night ag6 then he
said that he just assumed that it would
be working because all the pieces were
involved and then later as kper was
thinking he kind of unravel the
variations this is like that but like 10
notches down okay we're not I'm not
comparing myself to kaspar but uh my
variations here are a lot simpler but
it's kind of the same idea a lot of
times you just you can just start
calculating your opponent's turn and um
that way you also save some time
so actually after Bishop to F7 like I
said my opponent played King to h8 but
after this the position was very smooth
now uh there are not as many threats
right like Knight to F2 is not something
that we need to worry about the bishop
on F7 is completely safe position is
fine we just have to uh make sure that
the that the black pieces don't have any
threats and then we consolidate our
position and continue with the attack
right after this the game is not that
interesting it actually continued
uh with H3 kicking the Knight away
Knight to E3 and even though it seems
like a problem because two of my pieces
are attacked the queen of C2 and The
Rook on F1 I actually have Queen
F2 with a pin and it helps the fact that
all of the black pieces are very
uncoordinated right like the bishop on
D7 has nothing to do with this Knight
the two Rooks sure I guess they are both
um coordinated but they no neither of
them can come to the eile right uh well
I guess you can't play Rook Rook E8 but
that's what happened in the game which
I'm GNA show in a second um
but yeah and at the same time the queen
on D4 has no protector so the Knight is
actually stuck and overall the position
is quite unpleasant for black because
there are even threats you know like of
queen of six if this Queen ever moves
right so uh just to quickly show Rook E8
was played Knight to D1 Rook to E7 try
to get some counter chances on the file
but after Knight takes E3 takes takes uh
we get to a position where not only do I
have two Rooks for a queen which usually
is winning material but at the same time
I'm also a pawn
up yeah Pawn up right so Queen D2 was
played but then Rook D1 takes
takes and eventually it took a little
bit of of conversion but I managed to to
win my game right it went on for
maybe uh he went on for longer than
expected actually he went on for like 20
more moves but uh this is actually just
completely
winning so yeah it all kind of has to do
with you know deciding to commit to a
move in this case Bishop takes G6 and
then making sure that um that it
actually works right so it's not only
having the confidence to come to a move
that completely changes the the game but
at the same time uh I wouldn't say 20
moves of pure technique but it was
pretty it was pretty decent like my
opponent didn't really have a chance
after but I don't know if pure technique
uh but thanks but um yeah so not only
does it have to do with like building up
the confidence to commit to a sacrifice
right knowing that there's no way back
but at the same time you have to keep a
cool mind and actually calculate all of
the defensive resources that the
opponent has in this case Knight to G4
which is kind of what I wanted to
highlight
um uh no I'm not seriously not comparing
myself to Magnus here I don't have
anywhere uh close to the
technique but okay so I feel like this
was a decent example now there's another
one that I wanted to
show which is this one and this one is a
little bit different
yeah this one is a little bit different
here we have a more uh we can say like
calm position like more chill
overall and this is actually from a game
of mine against um International master
nazzi bakit in the 2022 US championships
and I thought it was a very interesting
game I thought it was quite instructive
too uh because first of all we're not
going to be focusing on like direct
sacrifices this one's more of decision
making
right uh the the game actually stemmed
from a queen's Indian and my opponent's
last move was
B6
now before anything before we start
talking about moves I want to ask
questions about what do you think again
like how do you evaluate this position
what are some of the key aspects what do
you think white should do uh what do you
think black should do what are either
side lacking
right because there is U there's some
imbalance in the position but I hope you
explain it to me and then I'll explain
it to you so
yeah Bishops and
pawns um more accurate words have never
been said so exactly space very true I
agree
no you're not getting the little white
arrows
anymore it you know they have been
disqualified
so just look at the Bishops they want it
let them let them
cook well the question is like what are
they cooking right
like you
know what what Cuisine do they want to
cook today
because it can go one way it can go
another way it can get very Dynamic it
can be very chill
like you
know it can be spicy it can be like you
know what is it like long cooked meal
like there there's a lot going on
so I just have some questions I feel
like the the basics of this position is
quite easy to understand the fact that I
with the white pieces have a lot of
space and then my opponent's uh
development is a little bit more
restricted but at the same time black
has a Target right which is my Center
like I have to be really careful of what
I do with my
Center
um because there can be a lot of threats
against it but at the same time I can
use my Center to build up uh momentum
behind it right that's kind of like a
barrier and a chw
and then uh behind the the pawn chain I
can regroup all of my pieces so that I
can have a breakthrough right and at the
same time my advantage lies with space
which means that it has to do with
Dynamics and um kind of like reacting
quickly in a position meanwhile for
black they want to trade a few pieces
get a little bit more space and then
attack my Pawn structure right so for me
it's more beneficial to to keep pieces
on the board and to uh get the
initiative so based off of that what
would you do in this position here just
like as a general
question H this wasn't the four pawns it
was um it was a u Queen's
Indian like the bishop B4 check Knight
D2 castles A3 um Bishop back and E4
variation
oh yeah welcome to the stream n how's it
going okay so we're we we're going
strong with E5 any other
suggestions also like I want you to
think deeper than one move so you gotta
give me like variation at
least that's essentially everything we
learned about from the previous example
so
we also have we had E5 now we also have
Knight D5 and then if Knight takes C
takes and then this bishop will be
useless and then this Pawn will be
backwards that is true Knight D5 is a
move to
consider I will go for E5 as a blitz
move and then just see what happens yeah
so that's kind of calling into your
intuition right like E5 have some sort
of breakthrough in the
position I'm also wondering like two
people have suggested E5 but like you
need to explain to me what happens after
takes takes night
takes because I have
questions and they need to be answered
um so
yeah after regrouping pieces maybe C5 at
the right moment interesting there's
also Knight F3 and Knight D4 wish I wish
I could do that but my Pawn on e4 is a
little bit compromised so after Knight
F3 maybe there's going to be like Knight
E4 or something
so keep that in
mind any other last suggestions before
we actually move
on I like how you guys think about e but
not C5 I'm going to ask you what do you
think about C5
here because I feel like it's a slightly
better version of E5
so okay so there's one comment for C5
any
ideas like is it is it a good move is it
a bad move obviously it's wanting to
open up the diagonal um that the queen
has and put some pressure here on F7
right maybe the bishop can come here too
and it seems like less committal than E5
because E5 is also opening up the center
and we don't necessarily want to to open
up this file because the KN on E3 is our
worst piece right it's kind of misplaced
there if the Knight was on F3 it's a
completely different position but
unfortunately my knight is on E3 so
yeah so what do you think about
C5 and again like imagine this is your
game right so you don't know if this is
the right moment to break through or if
you're just you know going down the path
of the game where you're going to to be
worse for the for the rest of the game
and then you have to
to um to hold because you had one pretty
idea but it didn't work right so like
you really have to to balance it out and
it requires a lot of thinking a lot of
committ and that's kind of where your
intuition comes in right because it
tells you hey this is a good idea or hey
this is a bad idea
so you guys can't just comment C5 in the
chat because I said what do you think
about C5 so I'm asking more
like what do you think of of the move
right like do you think it has some
potential
um or is doesn't
not C5 looks like a hun kind of move
well uh if I tell you that I played C5
what would you
say so
yeah
C5 what do you guys think
C5 A4 you kind of have to calculate
right like C5 A4 probably the queen will
go to A2 to keep the threats here but
yeah I won't say anything but not sure
about cnick I think cnick will be fine
with my
decision maximum piece
activation Okay so so from what I can
understand you guys can correct me but
from what I can understand is that most
of you once I mention C5 realize that
it's a very interesting move right and I
feel like it does have some merits
because after C5 we're going to bring
the bishop to C4 black has to do
something about F7 and then the idea of
E5 is still at large right and if we
kick this KN away from F6 and the Knight
can come to D5 maybe the bishop can also
come to D5 there are just a lot of ideas
right
after C5 there are so many lines well
this is why we calculate so yeah
um so okay C5 like I said it's the move
that I put in the game but guess what C5
is actually incorrect it's not a good
move it's not horrible it's like
um maybe tiny Advantage for black but
white still has a lot of play
the funny thing is that it's actually
difficult to believe that this move
works when my pieces are not at their
best right like this Rook on A1 is not
really doing anything the Knight on
E3 it's on a at a very awkward spot
right so it's unclear whether things are
going to work or not and again I have no
pressure to break through the
position at this point because
black has very limited space so there's
no need for me to completely shift the
position right now because black is
already limited right I'm not limiting
with C5 in fact I'm giving a few extra
options to Black
right and the very funny thing is that
back when I played this game I think the
day the night of it was the rest day
sorry the night before the rest day
right like next day we had rest day so
so that night I was hanging out with
some friends I was talking with The
Grandmaster we're talking about this
game because it was actually a very
interesting game like after this move C5
might not have been the most accurate
but it led to very interesting positions
and um we're talking about this specific
position and then I asked my friend a
Grandmaster what would you do here and
he said well of course I would play
rookie won so simple makes a lot of
sense and I was like but didn't you
didn't even consider C5 and he was like
no why would I it looks
bad it looks bad because the pieces are
not ready it's so obvious and I was
like
oh
so so that was um a little bit of a
learning moment for me and it does make
it does make a lot of sense right
because why would I practically speaking
right like why would I spend so much
time to force basically Force C5 to work
in my
mind so that I can you know have an
interesting
position but I don't know what's going
on like why would I spend so much time
and energy to force a variation to work
that doesn't originally look like it's
working right because C5 is kind of an
ugly move if you think about it since
there are so many things that need to to
be taken into
consideration uh there's just a lot
going on it's a move that's a little too
intense for the position right now why
would I even um why would I even think
about
this right um so logically
actually a lot of times if a move is if
if a move it's ugly the general
consensus is that it's not good so just
keep that in mind Rook A1 on the other
hand makes so much more sense uh because
it's improving the position it's
bringing the Rook over to the E file
it's going to put some some
reinforcement on e4 right uh which is
weak and then at the same time I'm
building up the idea to go Knight D5 uh
my Rook is much better off in the
center um and you know in general I'm
just going to slowly but surely improve
the position because what I need to do
here is to keep the
tension and then try to
slowly suffocate my opponent because
they just don't have enough space
right so um um that would have been a
much better idea and then for example
let's say after Bishop to B7 uh we can
obviously just play Knight D5 and the
position is completely fine I would
personally say that after takes takes um
C5 B5 the position is easier to play as
easier to play as white it's just a lot
more comfortable I would say uh because
of all of the you know all of the space
that that we have but funny enough even
if we play a move like Bishop to C3 just
to reinforce the position it's actually
very interesting because even if you let
um even if you let uh black capture this
Pawn after Rook takes whoops Rook takes
Knight
D5 black has no moves right like they
manag to get the pawn on e4 but opening
files only works for white in this case
because uh literally black has no moves
no space no coordination so taking on e4
would have been a really big mistake in
fact and now C7 is in trouble the E4
Rook is in trouble if you give me the E
file I will break through uh there is
some tension between these two Bishops
and then the dark squares around the
king are going to be weak so actually
the position is like clearly better if
Rook takes takes uh there is just like
too much uh going on right and then most
likely black will have to give up this
C7
Pawn
so actually that would have been a lot a
lot better just Rook A1 it would have
saved me a lot of time a lot of energy
and it would have kept my position
slightly
better however like I said I played C5 I
still stand by the original essence of
this move you know like try to make the
position interesting but maybe I would
play C5 in a Blitz game where I'm not
risking anything but this is a big very
important classical game right so um in
a classical game for sure I would I
would um reconsider
C5 A4 is actually probably the strongest
variation because the whole point is
that um let's say if like
takes uh if takes and there's Bishop C4
Queen A7 and then here I wanted to play
Knight D5 takes takes uh Rook B8 and
then this was my points right that at
the end I have Queen C3 and then I can
take the pawn so this is what I wanted
to
do but um it's uh it's not so
easy because of A4 first and then
actually after Queen A2 after Queen A2
takes Bishop C4 Rook E7 Rook E7 was
played Queen E7 was another
option um Queen E7 was another option
but even here the position is just very
complicated um and the rest of the game
is not that important like I said there
were a lot of UPS and downs we quickly
reached time trouble because uh there's
just like way too much to calculate in
the position there were a lot of ups and
downs I was actually winning in the end
game but I couldn't find a way
to somehow just like at the board I
couldn't find a way to break through and
we ended up repeating and making a draw
so um it was overall just a very
interesting game I just thought that
this was a very critical moment
because um yeah the game was actually
very interesting after that but it
doesn't really pertain to our topic
today um but what I wanted to talk about
was like this specific moment because
it's a very normal position it's a
position that any of you watching could
easily have uh in your own games and
it's not as much about remembering this
specific position and trying to play
exactly as I should have done in your
own games but more of like capturing the
idea right that before you do any form
of breakthrough you really have to have
all of your pieces involved uh you have
to make sure there are no weak links
right um and overall just understand um
when your position is ready and when
it's not
right so if you can keep on improving
your position before having that
breakthrough because it's really not
going anywhere then just improve all of
your pieces before that um and that's
what I should have done here but
unfortunately I didn't but it works as a
as a learning
experience so if there are no more
questions about this particular example
then we can kind of already uh jump onto
the last one that I had planned for for
today uh which I think is also very
interesting and it brings me a lot of
fun memories actually if it loads okay
perfect um so this is a game from the
last round of Serbia open which I played
over the the summer last year I had a
lot of fun in that tournament I went
through this like um
European
um how should I say like tournament
tour um I had a lot of fun in all of my
events Ser open and was a really fun
tournament to play hopefully I can I can
go back again this year um and this is
the last last round game I can't
remember exactly what I was doing but I
do remember that this game was at
like 9 or 10:00 a.m. and I went to sleep
at like 2: or
three so again I don't remember what I
was doing I was I also got sick in that
tournament maybe that had to do with it
but I was like Jesus Christ what am I
going to play tomorrow I haven't even
prepped and I need to sleep um so I
ended up playing uh this very funky
variation In the Sicilian um it kind of
transposed just to like a regular nidorf
and then there were a lot of um
breakthroughs in the center I was
letting my opponent captur some of the
queen side pawns to um open up some
files so that I can attack and we find
ourselves in this very peculiar position
right because my opponent also uh gave
up some material if you just you know do
the first step of um evaluating a
position which is material and Counting
you would realize that I have an extra
Bishop I have my PA of Bishops which if
anyone watches any of my content you
know that I'm very excited about um
having the pair of Bishops whenever the
opportunity
arises and in this particular case I do
have an extra Bishop but unfortunately I
am two pawns down right uh my king is
very very open on
D7 but I wouldn't say that the white
king is necessarily super safe either
right because it's a sicilian any
Anything Can
Happen um so we have encountered this
position there are a lot of threats
going on uh one of them being Rook takes
E7 I am sure that when my opponent there
were a lot of complications before
getting to this point um there were a
lot of forcing moves and I'm sure that
my opponent just didn't take into
account the the move that I played in
this position um and he thought that he
would be fine with initiative but um it
all kind of has to do not just with
um not just with evaluation and trying
to understand the subtities of the
position but also a lot of calculation
right and kind of like a little bit of
that killer instinct which is important
if you're playing sharp openings so what
do you think I did here with the black
pieces again committing to a move right
like if we're going to go for it we're
going to go for it and it's going to
work
wasn't this morphe Innovation preparing
tactics by focusing on development I
don't know if he was the first one to
think about this but for sure he was
very big innovator I always love going
back to like those watching games from
like 1800s or like early
1900s uh especially before steinet there
was like this ramantic style of Chess
which is very exciting because it often
has to do with material versus time
right right or like material versus
development and a lot of times one side
gives up a lot of material so that they
can develop a few pieces and then
because the opponent was so busy
capturing pieces then they're able to
Checkmate the King right which is very
very fun right it's very beautiful
nowadays it doesn't work as easily
because defense has improved a lot um
but it's always fun to to
see
so we have two suggestions for Rook B2
and we have one for Queen G7 but again I
need to see full variations because if
you're telling
me that you want to play Rook
G2 obviously white is going to capture
back right so I need a little bit more
context I'm not just going to be like oh
great job Rook B2
um and end it there because if you're
when you're playing a real game like you
you're not just like oh Rook B2 and then
the move next move you're like okay
let's figure it out now like you figure
it all out before it happens right
so okay so I like what I'm seeing Rook
B2 King takes B2 Rook B8 uh then there
is an idea of Rook A8 right so if the
King goes to to the a file that is true
because and the White Queen gets pinned
right and the last move from that Queen
was Queen takes A6 so you could think
that this was all
calculating um but so Rook B2 King takes
Rook B1 there's Knight B5 right Knight
B5 we can't really afford to take with
the bishop because there are too many
threats like for example Rook takes
E7 um or even Queen E7 uh Queen A7 so um
after Knight to B5 we have to take with
the rook and then the can either go to
C3 to
A2 and it's really important to to take
all of those moves into consideration
and the material as well into
consideration because after Knight to B5
Rook takes then we have two Bishops for
uh two Bishops for Rook which is still
more than enough material considering
that the that the black king that the
white king is out in the
open
I did say that two Rooks for a queen is
a more favorable trade but you also have
to understand the subtleties of the
position so yes Rook takes B2 is a move
that I decided to play it's actually um
a very obvious in intuitive idea but you
really have to make sure that it works
so you commit to it right and the point
is that after takes Rook B8 the king uh
If It Moves it has to go to the a file
let's say like King A1 and yes I did say
that two Rooks are better than a queen
but you got to pay attention to this
position because it's not two Rooks it's
two Rooks and a bishop right and not
only that it's uh a queen and a pair of
Bishops literally the most deadly
combination that you could have and the
white king is very open right so there
are ideas of Bishop F6 which are not
going to be easy to face the pawn on H4
is hanging the queen can go like Queen
H4 Queen B4 something like that how are
these two Rooks going to do anything
right so it's not it it it's not just
like two Rooks versus a queen there are
a lot more elements taken into account
in general the two Rooks work better if
they coordinate uh but if the if the
king is wide open then the queen can be
very dangerous right and in this case
it's not just the queen like I said also
a pair of
Bishops um so this is completely winning
for for for black there's no um
there's no way around
it
so if instead of King A1 then Knight to
B5 which is the move that we need to
consider then uh like I said we don't
really have time for Bishop B5 because
there's Queen A7 and there are just way
too many uh too many elements going on
in this
position but we do something else
right
where's the winning continuation like
Rook B5 let's say King A2 how does how
does black Ure the
win I believe there's more than one way
to win but I I'm confident that I found
the quickest
so again it may look a little scary
because the the king is in the center
and there are always the ideas of Rook
E7 but at the same time um we have
enough time right like the the white
king is in even worse shape
so what to
do
Rook B8 threatening Rook
A8 maybe but you also again like have to
consider the fact that it might be a
little slow
like for
example rot B8 maybe takes takes and
then takes and then if Queen in
here C4 oh wait no there is check here
oh my God I almost missed that
wow so
intelligent
um maybe just Rook
D5 probably is still good but
um I would say that white has a lot more
chances than before
so Queen H5 probably works but the the
move that I decided to play was actually
Queen G7 and I think this move is really
good because there's not much that that
um that white can do here and it all
kind of has to do a little bit with the
with the geometry of the board which I
find to be quite beautiful uh Queen G7
not only not only does it create a
threat right with Queen B2 but at the
same time it keeps an eye on the bishop
on E7 right so if Rook takes Queen takes
there's never going to be anything um if
Queen A7 then there's going to be Rook
B7 s which is actually what happened in
the game I'm going to show later uh if
Rook B1 trying to to protect from the
Checkmate then there's Bishop
D5 and you know if King A3 then Queen
C3 so it's completely winning um
actually if King A4 I'm just going to
show the variation there is Queen C4 and
queen A2 so that's quite
nice and just to briefly show um
what happened in the
game actually before that I'm going to
show you what happens if Queen A3 which
is also quite nice there's Queen to G8
King A1 and then Bishop to
F6 and then after um after
C3 uh we have the really beautiful
Bishop takes takes and because the queen
is giving a check on G8 and not on F7 we
actually have Queen A8 so we have
the kind of like a latter Checkmate and
there's no way to to recover from
it so the two Bishops are pretty strong
with the queen covering and then there's
going to be a a Checkmate on A8 and then
what happened in the game is not too
different from that uh Queen A7 happened
Rook B7 Queen D4 but here there is just
Queen G8 right and then Queen
A8 so yeah it's funny that the queen was
on H6 not doing much then it went to G7
and then he had like this um very nice
idea so based on three on this three
different examples the first one kind of
had to do with committing to a sacrifice
and then making sure that uh you can
take into account and properly calculate
the defenses that the opponent can can
have um the second one revolted around
deciding whether or not to have a
breakthrough in the position in the
particular case it was better to keep
improving the pieces before actually
breaking through with C5 uh it wasn't
necessarily horrible but it was just a
an inaccurate move right like there's no
need to like I said there's no need to
spend so much time and energy and um you
know like kind of wasting yourself
trying to force a move to work when you
can just like slowly improve your
position and then you're not going to um
you're not going to lose that
breakthrough ID until next turn right uh
and then this final example is when the
position is very sharp uh maybe you can
sense that you're a little bit better
already kind of combined um um
committing through a move to also like
the Killer Instinct and like breaking
through the the opponent's castled king
with Rook
B2 so yeah those were the three examples
that I wanted to to show today I hope
you guys um enjoyed and I think with
that we're going to be ending the stream
right oh yes whatever you'd like all
right peace out everyone
bye-bye
[Music]
he